on december 7 2021 ubisoft announced its
first project in the nft space titled
ubisoft quartz and while this isn't the
first time nfts and games have crossed
paths it is the first time a triple-a
studio has entered the fray and it most
likely won't be the last so what might
nfts mean for the gaming industry going
forward and what the hell are these nft
things anyway in this video we're going
to talk about that and more however if
you already know what nfts are then feel
free to skip ahead to the more
gamer-centric stuff no hard feelings i
promise
for starters the letters nft stand for
non-fungible token but an easier way to
think about this is non-replaceable
token an example i've seen quite a lot
is the mona lisa it's unique and can't
be replaced by something like a mona
lisa poster whereas a dollar bill is
fungible i can replace it with another
dollar bill because they hold the same
value
well not when you combine them because
then that makes two dollars i'm talking
about if i lost one of them an nft can
be things like art music and even memes
but it's important to note that unlike
the mona lisa or my dollar bill nfts
aren't physical items instead their
digital code stored and secured on a
blockchain simply put the blockchain is
a digital form of recordkeeping think of
it like a bank statement or a cvs
receipt just a really long list of
transactions but this list isn't just
yours it's a part of a peer-to-peer
network meaning other people have access
to it as well and each new transaction
isn't bounced between banks in order to
be verified it's checked by every
computer that has a copy of that list
it's decentralized and its structure
essentially makes the timeline of data
slash transactions nearly impossible to
tamper with maintaining the blockchain
and facilitating all of the transactions
that take place requires incredible
amounts of processing power and
according to a report from bbc tech
bitcoin blockchain consumes more
electricity in a year than all of
argentina so needless to say it's
horrible for our environment nfts exist
on various blockchains but most being
sold are found on the ethereum
blockchain ethereum reportedly uses less
electricity but it's far from being
emission free
back on december 7 2021 ubisoft
announced its first nft project titled
ubisoft quartz however they're not the
first to merge gaming in nfts as a
matter of fact the first big use case
was actually a game called cryptokitties
this game launched in 2017 and allows
players to purchase nfts for specific
digital cats these cats can then breed
with other digital cat purchases and
produce entirely new cats that can then
be sold as unique nfts of their own this
market has generated millions since its
inception with some single cats costing
well over a million dollars alone axi
infinity is a turn-based combat game in
which users can raise battle and trade
fantasy creatures called axes i've heard
it called pokemon on the blockchain but
for some reason i don't like to think
about it that way the game is made by
vietnam-based sky mavis which was
founded in 2018 and is now valued at 3
billion
axiomfinity was reportedly inspired by
cryptokitties and extremely rare axes
can reportedly go for more than 1
million
another example is the sandbox a
community driven creative space that
lets users create voxel-based assets or
gaming experiences you could say it's
similar to roblox outside of the fact
that these gaming experience all exist
on finite virtual lan that users can buy
using nfts the tokens correlate to a
piece of land where you can host game
creations for other players to visit
with the value of the size and position
of the land determined by simple supply
and demand but on the other side of
things now we have the first aaa nft
project in ubisoft quartz courts will
wrap up in-game cosmetics into their own
nfts each of which will have a unique
serial number and history of owners
these items called digits can then be
freely traded between players for agreed
upon prices with a natural economy
forming around these transactions and
the scarcity of the items the program
which is still in beta is currently
supported by ghost recon breakpoint on
pc and only available in certain regions
despite using a decentralized system
called tezos this blockchain uses proof
of stake as opposed to the energy-hungry
proof of work blockchains such as
bitcoin and ethereum leading ubisoft to
call its venture quote energy efficient
but did ubisoft need to use blockchain
technology at all one of the supposed
advantages of blockchain is that it's
decentralized but in the case of quartz
digits are stuck in ubisoft's ecosystem
available in a handful of countries and
is only authorized to be traded on two
third-party platforms so to me quartz is
just the same old in-game cosmetic
system except now it's wearing a costume
and trying to fool you into doing things
a different way it's hard for me to
believe that these exclusive items
couldn't have been implemented without
blockchain as kyle orland of rs technica
puts it quote a basic centrally
controlled database could do the same
thing much more simply
according to ubisoft this is the first
step in what will be a four year venture
into blockchain technology and the
company's pursuit of its own metaverse
at the time of this recording digit
support has not been announced for any
other games but given ubisoft's large
library my guess is it's only a matter
of time before that changes that is of
course assuming that this first run
within break point is a successful one
the game's first 2 000 digits were
released on november 9th and quickly
sold out so there are clearly people
interested however when you weigh that
number against the over 20 000 that
dislike the announcement video you start
to see that the negative reception far
outweighs the positive but ubisoft
aren't the only publisher looking at
blockchain technologies and nfts in
particular companies like ea take 2 and
even square enix are enthusiastic about
the venture ea ceo andrew wilson even
went as far as to call nft and
blockchain games quote the future of our
industry during an earnings call a
statement that's not too far off from
ubisoft's ceo calling it a quote
revolution in the industry meanwhile
valve is taking steps to keep it away
from their platform back in october the
company revealed games that use
blockchain technology or let users
exchange nfts and cryptocurrencies will
not be allowed on steam steam's
competitor the epic game store does not
have such a policy in place and told the
verge it's open to the idea of games
that use nfts and cryptos so where are
we headed from here honestly it's
too hard to know for sure to investors
and crypto enthusiasts nfts and video
games might seem like a match made in
heaven however to the gaming community
who have been fighting against micro
transactions and loot boxes for years
this is just another way for publishers
to cash in on the next big thing and
that's what's worrisome for me we've
already seen certain non-free to play
games get stripped of proper progression
in order to push microtransactions so
how long until we see nft shift gaming
experiences in a similar way and what
happens when the other publishers join
in are they going to choose something
energy efficient as well or is the
environment going to take another hit
for some subjectively cool looking
helmet in a video game the harsh reality
is that we're definitely going to see
more companies take steps forward in
this space throughout 2022 and when i
say that i'm including them talking
about their plans even further as well
as actually launching court's
competitors however there is a massive
divide between the people who are for it
and those who are against it so it's
unclear just how successful any of those
ventures will become by 2023 similar to
fads like motion controls 3d gaming and
in some cases vr and battle royales
companies just see dollar signs and want
their piece of the pie so if this video
tells you anything make sure you hit the
like button because it's also now in nft
selling for a million dollars put the
money right here right here and it's all
yours this rare video all yours
[Music]